men can always say things like oh i
don't care if my girl makes more money
than me alpha man will always care if a
woman makes more money than them a
hundred dollars
word what's happening on this podcast an
alpha male do you think i would care if
my girl makes my money than me i don't
i'm
yeah like you know i would care i don't
consider you alpha man yeah but i wait a
minute
wait a minute whoa
what did you say to me
you know before we would start
get an elf
can i bronze with you
yeah that's pontificate
this whole alpha beta [ __ ] is so cringe
when people use this
as an alpha male i would i mean
things are there
okay they're there red pill purple pill
blue pill things are there they're in
place they're in this environment
called the world
now people take it
and they smudge it in your face that's
what makes it cringe
so i have to say it you don't have to
just saying as an alpha male it removes
you points
alpha points and just me saying alpha
points makes it even more cringier you
understand what i'm saying it's all
there we know
but people
like to okay that now okay
it's the thing
alpha is the thing okay i'm gonna refer
to that then so that people understand
you know what bump this topic go on
you're on youtube right now going
youtube search
go on youtube search right now give me
this [ __ ] today we're going to be
talking about
why sigma mills are more attractive than
alpha males
now a lot of people didn't even know
that sigma males existed until last week
because you just made that [ __ ] up
what you not down with the sigma males
[ __ ] it's beta that's it well listen i
said keep kappa kappa as an alpha pi uh
alpha pi kappa alpha pi kappa that
stands for album preach comedy i've been
preaching coming dude
no
no no you gotta do it you gotta do it
you gotta do this
no you don't you're not you're not ready
too that's another that's not the yard
that's another fraternity
that's another fraternity using matrix
references [ __ ] y'all take that [ __ ]
way too seriously and way too far beta
at least he's funny
jesse lee peterson he's hilarious yeah
beta
he's the only person who i'm fine with
hearing better from i am a nurse
a nurse
no he's not faith it's not beta
it's like you're saying baby
baby
beta
beta a nurse
press play against what he said remark
are you the head of your wife
i like to think that we're equal are you
there
i am i am a i know no no i'm an alpha uh
not if you think you're your wife are
equal vader
oh just a little girl a little girl
if you have a little girl a beta
what's your name destiny
he's a
beta
he's the only one that i'll accept it
from but it's still cringe
it's murder it's funny though you think
it's funny
beta
[Laughter]
you go to work
can you take breaks yeah
are you hot do you need water how about
i can drink it
alpha males don't get don't get thirsty
no don't get thirsty because thirsty
[ __ ]
some rick james [ __ ] yeah so we're
having this debate in the manosphere
about alphas and sigmas so today we're
going to go ahead and break down the
alphas and sigmas now
to most of you guys
your definition this is when like dc
nerds start arguing about the origin
story of batman it's just like no his
dad died before his mom no she got shot
first like [ __ ] who cares they both
dead
why are we talking about this he a whole
orphan okay we don't care but at least
they know it's fiction this [ __ ] that
they talking about this corny ass [ __ ]
that's nerd [ __ ] it'd be like they're
like ass batman i know when my mom died
shut up that is some nerd [ __ ] that's
not [ __ ]
that is just uh
your definition
of a alpha male is a guy who has money
who has women
and who is good-looking i've seen the
alpha man broke but he's still alpha
bro everyone got a different definition
let's just let him let me then so what's
the use of it if everybody got a whole
definition right man words
hey just hit play we'll see where this
goes
that's what you've been taught uh alpha
male is
all right what we're gonna do is we're
gonna break down those little
characteristics all right can beta males
have money
yes
majority of the successful men in the
world
are beta metals you have to understand
no matter if your alpha no matter if
your sigma your beta omega delta zelta
whatever these mindsets are
um midtown red pill blue pill it's all
mindsets
when your mind change
so does the type of guy that you are
all right it's all about how confident
you are to society when it comes to
these different mindsets
but when it comes to the definition of
them and what you've been taught
every man can have money and still be
weak
every man can have women and still be
weak a lot of you better guys had women
the women just used you
when it comes to alpha male the alpha
male doesn't get used by a woman
now when it comes to good looks how many
beta males out there are good looking a
lot of beta males so when it comes to
the money when it comes to the women and
it comes to the good looks they do not
apply
to an alpha male
nor do they apply to a beta male because
these are things that can exist in every
sign so we're going to take that and
throw it to the side i don't want you to
use that as definition what we're going
to break down is the psychology of
things
all right
when it comes to alpha and beta
the alpha males
lead the beta males
period
all right sigma males are a form of
alpha males the difference is
alphas are known for lions for a reason
because lions conquer everything around
them
that's what they do i'm about to throw
my own phone
[Music]
chris boss
someone said this to me he said
the whole manosphere lingo is like
astrology for men yes
this is corny
i'm so glad that when i came up this
[ __ ] wasn't prominent
i'm so glad
to me it was just like listen you like
talking to girls here's some ideas bang
bang they didn't use a bunch of cringe
ass terms and all this other
i'm so glad
astrology is space racism
atmosphere is ground racism
that's why we're looking at it it's so
cringy but they have all this lingo and
people hit me up as a purple pill bro
what the [ __ ] are you talking about me
did you just hear what the words that
came out of your mouth you brought
superhero lingo to a real world
conversation yeah whatever you're beta
male blue pill
online bruh oh i don't know what tell
you guys
am i crazy for saying it looks dumb
anyways appreciate you guys hopefully
you guys enjoyed today's video let us
know and if you guys want to hear a
single from preach one
[Music]
foreign
that's part of our merch
alpha pi kappa what does that mean album
preach comedy really that's what i set
it up like that's why i'm in charge of
the merch
yeah because we have we have some shirts
they say alpha podcast as far as our
fraternity goes my only concern is
making sure that chris brown survives
that [ __ ] just can't die he can't die
not before the movie starts he can't die
i get dibs on now making good oh man
yeah how are you talking yeah i get dips
well but megan good old old you don't
like them old girls
i don't but you know what no
megan goods on my side she's on your
side yeah yeah but you're married
doesn't matter
she good
doesn't matter oh priest just said that
about his
megan good it's making it's making good
i mean there's some people hold on
there's some people that my girl she was
like oh he's sex and i'm like
yeah
all right i ain't gotta say [ __ ] i can't
say [ __ ] if you've never seen stomp the
yard y'all miss no no no no no no no it
sounds like
it sounds like it sounds exact it sounds
like
the dude
on that track from justin timberlake
[Music]
dog